- On this episode, I talk
about the Apple Watch,
setting goals, and I get deep.
(dramatic music)
Hey, everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and you're watching the
#AskGaryVee Show, Episode 16.
Fun fact about the number 16.
I dislike the number.
- [Voiceover] Santiago asks,
"What do you think about the Apple Watch?"
- Santiago, I, I've been
here in Atlantic City
all week and did not
watch the performance,
so I actually know very
little about the Apple Watch.
I think it's kind of ironic
that Steve's asking me
this question.
But I chose to answer it, and here's why.
I'm gonna answer it philosophically.
I actually didn't see all
the bells and whistles.
I literally know nothing
about the Apple Watch.
I saw like some random
picture in a Twitter feed,
but here's what I do know.
This becomes this.
And then this becomes this.
We are absolutely 100% going robotic.
And I mean over the course of the next
100 plus years and so the evolution of
information being closer to us
started with something
that looked like this,
well, further back,
you go back and then evolve to something
that was always on us.
Now it's gonna be like even closer,
like not even going in the pocket.
Google Glass and things of that nature
I think are underrated.
I think more of that kind
of stuff is coming as well.
And so I think it's evolution.
The human evolution.
- Hey, Gary, how's it going.
My name is Adorian Deck.
I make YouTube videos, and I created the
Twitter account, OMG Facts.
Now I control and manage a
network of many different
accounts on many different
social platforms.
And my question for you today is
do you believe creating my own website
with valuable and original
content to drive traffic to
is a reasonable investment
for long-term branding?
Or do you believe that
websites are going to be
irrelevant eventually with
this mobile revolution
that's happening.
Should I be looking more
into app development
or something that I'm not even looking at?
Let me know, thanks.
- You know, I think that's
a really good question
a lot of people are struggling with.
I will say this.
That, you know, I have garyvaynerchuk.com.
Oh no, you can't link
it out, but link there.
Anyway, I have
garyvaynerchuk.com for a reason.
Not the kicks and giggles.
I want to have a platform
that I fundamentally control
all aspects of.
And so when you are
building brand on Twitter
with a bunch of Twitter accounts
like you are, like I am,
when you're building a Facebook fan page
and then all of a sudden
Facebook deems for itself
and for its audience and
for you, believe it or not,
that they need to drop down organic reach
and everything you're putting
out is not being delivered,
you start understanding why
having your own email service,
having your own website, matters.
Having your own app matters
if you deem that people are
gonna spend more of their time
within the app than on
a mobile native website.
Just because the world's
going mobile or wristy
or this, you know, or virtual reality,
doesn't necessarily mean
that the website is gone.
It's really just protocol
for a place that you can own.
And so what I would say is
philosophically, you wanna
have your own house.
But doing business in your
vacation home or in a hotel
also mattered.
If you understood that
analogy, you're on your way.
- [Voiceover] Kyle asks,
"Do you set and track
"personal/business goals -
aside from owning the Jets?
"What do you find useful in the process?"
You know, I really don't
set any business goals
other than to continue to gain leverage.
You know, pay forward.
Provide value to the audience.
Make money.
Keep it practical and ambitious.
But I don't have a goal of like,
"I'm gonna get VaynerMedia to 100 million
"and then this is gonna happen,"
or "The fund is gonna return three times
"its 25 million dollar
investment at Vayner RSE
"and then this will happen,"
or, "In four years, I'm gonna get into the
"car wash business."
I just don't go that route.
My route is really my fundamental play is
I always talk about my
one goal being the Jets
and for the hardcore people
that followed my career,
I'm gonna throw a little
bit of a curveball to you,
give you a little more fun fact.
That's kinda the thing that
I wanna do with this show.
The only other core strategy I have is
collecting people.
You know, finding the
individuals that I think
I can jam with for the next
15, 20, 30, 45
years professionally.
That to me is the global strategy.
Who can I do business with
as a teammate forever.
- What's up, Gary.
So, you know, I just quit my job at radio
after being on air since
I was 16 years old.
I kinda risked everything
for this new Dash Radio app.
I hope you've checked it out.
You've gotta tell me
your favorite station.
But what was the riskiest
thing you've ever
done in your career?
Because it was tough for me to leave
something I've been at for so long,
especially an institution
like traditional radio,
in order to try something new with zero
listeners today to disrupt that industry.
What was the toughest choice you ever made
in your life or in business
about leaving something
that you've done to do something new?
- You know, again, the
enormous excitement I have
behind doing this show
and thank you all for
allowing me to do this show,
is predicated on the fact
that I get to tell you
things you've never heard before.
I'm gonna say something
that I've never ever
ever ever ever ever have
talked about before.
Which is the toughest
professional thing I've ever done.
My cliche answer historically
has been, you know,
leaving the Wine Library
with is my first love,
and that's a very big truth.
But as I've started becoming
a little bit more in
tune with my own feelings
and have given this thought,
the toughest thing I ever had to do,
and Steve, pay attention to me.
You'll like this answer.
The toughest thing I ever had to do,
believe it or not,
was make the decision that I was okay with
putting myself out there.
You know, a lot of you
probably have at this point
forgotten because the Gary Vee persona and
narrative has taken over
my career and my Wikipedia
and things of that nature.
But the first 10 to 15
articles that have ever
been written about me in the
AP and the New York Times
and the Wall Street Journal was,
"Wiz Kid Builds Business."
That the establishment,
the business world,
the people that I look up to in ways,
maybe not specifically because I don't
really have heroes, but
respect their opinions
and their accomplishments.
I went from the narrative of being a great
business operator that
saw trends and executed it
for financial gain,
which is like something
everybody deems to be so noble in business
to being a self promoter,
to being a social media guru.
To being an author.
Making the decision that I could accept
the rolling of the eyes
of the Ivy League grads
or the establishment to get bigger reach,
to build audience to jam with people,
to be human and extroverted and
taking that step back
or two or three in the minds
of the top two or three percent
was a pretty interesting,
difficult decision for me.
Knowing what the consequences were of
putting myself out there
and that I would be
respected less for my
business accomplishments
because of it
wasn't the easiest thing
that I ever had to deal with
and something that's very honestly I still
continue to deal with.
I, now, this is where you
start getting into the,
I don't know, DRock, if you
wanna make it dark.
But this is where you start
getting into the darkest stuff.
In a weird way, I like the underestimation
that comes along with it as well.
Because the truth is the
reason that entrepreneurship
and business speaks to me
especially in an American context
is that the truth is undefeated.
That ultimately, you
know, if I go and execute
multiple hundred million dollar businesses
and make smart investments,
it's all net net, right?
Like you may not like
the fact that I don't
dress up or that I curse on
stage or that I self promote
or whatever you wanna call it.
But if I execute, you just have to eat it.
And so that was clearly,
DJ, that was clearly
the toughest thing for me, which was that
I was consciously self aware
that I was entering a realm
where I would start
becoming more disrespected
even though my accomplishments
were gonna be greater.
That mis-positioning was something that,
that was tough.
Question of the day.
Let's just actually, you know what?
That was such a profound question.
Question of the day.
What is the hardest thing you ever had
to do professionally?
Because let's be honest,
there's way tougher
things of raising a child
with a disability or bankruptcy or pain
or a lot of emotional stuff.
So in the context of business,
what is the toughest business challenge
that you've ever had to to deal with?
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.
(lively music)